we just got a major iPhone 15 lineup
leak that shows that Apple isn't just
planning on giving us another regular
update in September to bring the iPhone
in line with the competition but they're
actually planning on going all out and
leaving everyone else in the dust now
what I'm specifically talking about is
the battery life upgrade being better
than anyone expected due to the
combination of three things the chip the
battery size and more efficient
components so let's get right into it
starting with a new iPhone 15 lineup
battery leak from it home claiming that
the entire lineup is getting
significantly larger batteries as you
can see the regular iPhone 13 and 14 had
basically the same battery size but the
new 15 will feature an 18 larger battery
the 14 plus obviously had a much larger
battery than the 13 mini but the 15 plus
is gonna get even bigger being 14 larger
than the current model the 15 Pros
battery is also going to be 14 bigger
and then finally the 15 Pro Max will be
12 percent larger at
4852 milliamp hours which is actually
still smaller than many of the competing
Flagship smartphones like the Galaxy s23
Ultra with its 5000 milliamp hour
battery however the crazy thing is that
in various battery life test videos on
YouTube the iPhone 14 pro Max actually
beats out the s23 ultra even though that
phone has a 15 bigger battery in phone
Arena's recent battery life test video
the iPhone beat the Samsung and browsing
by eight minutes and YouTube playback by
over two hours phone Buffs video showed
the iPhone lasting 38 minutes longer and
the active screen on time test despite
having the much smaller battery and
finally JoJo's battery life test video
showed the iPhone destroying a bunch of
Flagship Android phones including the
s23 ultra and pixel 7 Pro by over an
hour and 20 minutes in a real-life test
so the point that I'm trying to make
here is that Apple's iPhone 14 pro Max
is incredibly efficient since it's still
able to beat out so many of those other
phones while having a smaller battery so
just by the iPhone 14 pro Max's battery
increasing by 12 percent up to almost 5
000 milliamp hours it's going to make
the new 15 Pro Max pull even more ahead
of the competition but guess what that's
only the beginning of the battery life
gains for the iPhone 15 lineup because
we have more leaks to discuss including
more efficient components first of all
one thing that's for sure is that the
iPhone 15 lineup is going to be getting
the new snapdragon x70 modem which has a
huge efficiency improvement over the
current x65 modem and the iPhone 14
lineup because of its new 5G power save
gen 3 technology the x70 will apparently
be up to 60 percent more efficient than
the x65 which will greatly help battery
life while using 5G data going further
taiwan's economic Daily News leaked a
big display upgrade for the iPhone 15
lineup a couple of months back stating
that the iPhone 15s will be using a more
power efficient OLED display driver chip
that's based on 28 nanometer Tech
instead of a current 40 nanometers
basically reducing power consumption of
the display which is probably the thing
that drains the most battery life on an
iPhone especially with high brightness
and that's not all because according to
Ming Chico the iPhone 15 lineup will
come with a brand new upgrade to the
ultra wideband chip which will be built
on a more advanced seven nanometer
process compared to the current 16
nanometers to once again reduce power
consumption so now we have efficiency
improvements for the display the ultra
wideband ship and the 5G modem
components but now we've got to talk
about the chips but first I've got to
give a shout out to our partner case
coup for their magic stand case which is
the best value case you can get since
it's very rugged high quality and
stylish while also featuring magnets for
all of your magsafe accessories but
making it even better the max a freeing
is actually on a hinge that works as a
finger grip and a stand at a variety of
different angles for things like
watching videos or even taking photos so
go ahead and check out the discount info
and Link down in the description below
now as we already know the regular
iPhone 14 and 14 plus are currently
still using the a15 bionic chip and with
the corresponding 15 models they're
finally going to get the a16 which is
definitely a decent Improvement in
efficiency but on the 15 Pro Models
that's where we're going to see a
massive difference which is why I keep
telling people to plan on upgrading to
the Pro Models because they're going to
be so much better it home even reported
that the 15 Pro Models will start with
an upgraded 256 gigs of storage as
standard which is double the amount the
regular 15s will get so keep that in
mind especially since we're expecting
the price to go up but getting back to
the chip discussion the Pro Models will
be getting the new a17 bionic chip which
is going to be a huge deal because it's
going to be the world's first chip built
on tsmc's brand new three nanometer
technology which basically means that
the transistors that do all the
processing inside of the chip will be
smaller than the current 5 nanometer
transistors and the main point of all of
that is a huge power efficiency
Improvement and if you're wondering how
much well tsmc's own chairman Mark Liu
has said that the new three nanometer
process will require 35 percent less
power while also providing better
performance than the previous five
nanometer process that right there is a
generational leap in power efficiency
Improvement especially since the a16 is
already so efficient compared to the
competition and they're gonna make the
a17 35 more efficient which is crazy
apparently this new three nanometer Chip
is going to be such a big deal for
performance and efficiency that digitime
said it'll lead to upgrades on the
iPhone 15 lineup which which will spark
huge upgrade demand among current iPhone
owners and I believe a big part of that
will be a massive Improvement in battery
life and if you consider all the other
factors I've mentioned in this video
including the 12 to 18 larger battery
sizes all of the various component
upgrades that are focused on using less
power and the new a17 Bionic chip built
on the latest three nanometer process it
seems like apple is planning to not only
give us a big battery life Improvement
but to exceed expectations for battery
life by so much that it'll be in a whole
different league and take years for
competing smartphones just to catch up
to the iPhone 15 Pro Max I'm talking
better life that's so good that some
users won't even have to recharge for
over two days straight just imagine how
convenient that would be and remember
that video I showed you where the iPhone
14 pro Max beat the the rest of the
competition in terms of battery life
well now imagine the iPhone lasting over
10 or 11 hours in a real world test and
the best part of all is that the battery
life will be only one aspect that's
getting a big upgrade this year we're
also expecting the 15 Pro Models to have
the thinnest bezels out of any
smartphone ever not only that but the
most performance in any smartphone ever
with the a17 bionic chip so with all of
that said you can probably imagine why
I'm so excited for the new iPhone 15
lineup and why I'm constantly telling
people to wait before upgrading their
iPhone because we only have about two
months left to go before September and I
definitely recommend waiting so
hopefully you guys enjoy this video and
if you have any of your own thoughts on
battery life let me know down in the
comment section below and click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
foreign